Lauren would you think of the tribute
tonight how was that bina oh man it was
it was moving just sitting there
watching his family react to the song
and it was a powerful moment an honor to
be there celebrating nipsey's life too
man I was real real touching bro like
the first time we really had a chance to
see his family you know out and about
and what did that mean to see them here
to man man like you said like everybody
coming together and just you know saying
just appreciate people right out here
you know that's what it's about you're
saying at the memorial service and then
being back here tonight was it a full
circle moment and how hard was that as
hard as you can imagine it to be but I
feel like sharing that with his family
each and every time as we always have we
all would have been here anyway so it's
trying to bring some joy and some life
back into this building back to near the
Staples Center because we've all you
know been here the beauty Awards each
and every year so we wanted to be happy
and for him to not be here and share in
this moment we can only hold on to the
premise say the way same way that his
mother does he's here he never left and
sharing that with my brothers fifteen
hundred nothing on that stage like we
would have done anyway in yg and John
Legend and Khaled he was there with us
and it's the hardest thing I think I've
ever had to I know they just far as
having who you would feel that industry
friends this was beyond that this is
someone that cared about me and I cared
about him and we cared about music and
we had conversations about things other
than just the norm and it's just an
absolute tragedy but at the same time
I'm glad everyone seen what he was able
to do in all of the 33 years that he was
and then we could celebrate him in this
way and we'll always do marathon
continues the marathon continues deuces
in here hustle me [ __ ] see
[Applause]
real